aber das ist eine frau auf die bühne
gehen alleine ein mikro selbstständig in
die hand nimmt und eine bühne
unterhalten ist unvorstellbar in meiner
heimat
hallo mein name ist legal ihre ich bin
schneller comedia es witzig flächen
politik oder das logo
[Musik]
andere märkte ist für mich das symbol
für meine freiheit hier natürlich
ankamen deutschland wo ich dachte so war
eine frau regiert hier ne absolute
wahnsinn
und ich bin wirklich traurig dass ich
jetzt deswegen kann weil ich erst einmal
gerne da einfach angie hin geschrieben
und jetzt kann ich bin jetzt auf dem weg
von köln nach mülheim an der ruhr weil
ich habe den alles sparen
[Musik]
also wir sind
natürlich immer fragende gesichter die
er so wirtschaftsflüchtlinge oder
politische flüchtlinge und bei uns was
bisschen anders gewesen meine mutter und
ich fand einfach dass uns kommst du dich
ja nicht so bestehen also dann den
feschen flüchtlinge
weil damit fraglich ob frau merkel als
bundeskanzlerin gewählt ein land wo eine
frau regiert im iran können die frauen
noch nicht mehr motorrad fahren was
wahrscheinlich auch besser wo ist
einfach mal so schulter sind voll
besteuert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute versuche ich meine eltern ich habe
euch waffen länger nicht gesehen ist
halt für den job sei selbständig in die
unterwegs ist und ich freu mich schon
auf
also etwas mehr ruhe habe ich generell
sehr wenig in dem job weil
es ist ja sowohl online aber auch
zuschauen bei gewissen beiträge ankommen
die performance ist es halt immer
irgendwas nur der kopf auf ihren anruf
oder social media checken und deshalb
mega wichtig für mich ein gefühl von
zugehörigkeit zu haben einfach mal an zu
kommen
[Musik]
auf einem alle comedian immer auf der
flucht vor kein mensch mit comedian der
so normal
zu hause das ist für mich immer das
gefühl einfach nicht mehr funktionieren
zu müssen einfach machen es sind zu
sitzen zu chillen zu entspannen da muss
ich nicht leisten da kann ich einfach
ich sein und das ist so das gefühl zu
hause zu sein
[Musik]
vom 3
mutter viacom ist schon traditionell
also es ist man halt viele im iran
haben die habe ich extra für mich
gekocht also die erste frage noch wenn
ich nach hause komme ist was gibt es zum
essen so ist immer erste frage schon
seitdem ich klein bin und wenn es kein
gutes essen gibt dann weiß ich umgehen
als überhaupt schwere mich ein
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch noch wo wir nach
deutschland frischt gezogen würden so
wie frisch er nun mal den kurs richtung
an den kopf und meinte
ich weiß nicht wer ich war ein bisschen
traurig aber ich wollte stoss weil meine
kinder in
deutschland in freiheit habe sehr gute
zukunft steht man als freier gehen ich
habe immer respekt gesetzt man muss man
alle muss also es ist ganze welt dass
leute nicht gleiche leute guter mensch
ich möchte menschen alle leute sind
nicht gleich
[Musik]
das thema integration ist super wichtig
nicht nur für mich so eine anpassung ist
ein instrument das leben generell
einfacher macht für alle und ich hatte
eine phase wo ich dann immer gesagt habe
ja deutschland scheiße weil ich mal
zurück wollte in die heimat und hat
meine mutter mir das sehr gut
beigebracht die so neu nicht das land
ist scheiße sondern deine einstellung
und wenn du dich an freunde ist mit der
situation wenn du dich hin gibt dann ist
alles viel besser und so war's dann
[Musik]
ich finde da durch das hier ist er nach
deutschland gekommen sind und die das in
erster linie für uns gemacht haben weil
ich meine eltern hatten in die heimat
alles und haben das für die kinder
gemacht ist das finde ich meine aufgabe
einfach nicht nur menschen zum lachen zu
bringen sondern auch meinen eltern zu
zeigen dass es geht das ist die richtige
entscheidung war und es ist einer meiner
größten motivation und einer der größten
gründe warum ich auch immer große
motivation habe immer noch mehr zu
erreichen
denn die merkel jetzt zwei stunden noch
mal sie jetzt nicht mehr wert aber wenn
ihr könntet würde sie noch mal wählen
würdest du merken ja ja wir
wissen ja wie es sein kann wenn man
keine demokratie hat wie im iran
und für mich ist natürlich jetzt wichtig
dass die politik einfach keine angst
macht dass menschen irgendwie beruhigt
des menschen antworten kriegen auf
youtube
welche partei ich wähle zwar geht nicht
warum
ich muss mir noch gedanken machen
ich wünsche mir hat heute politik das
ist nicht die im iran oder anderen
länder ist dass man keine demokratie hat
das menschen hungrig sind das menschen
probleme an dass man sie nicht ich
wünsche mir von der demokratie dass man
dass jede frage beantwortet über dass
menschen nicht ernst nehmen
[Musik]
ich habe ja in deutschen pass bekommen
es war echt sehr viel telefonieren würde
es da wirklich viele telefonate und es
war wichtig für mich den deutschland
passt vorhaben und vor allem ein echter
beim thema gesagt haben wenn du durch
bis dann darfst du überall hinreisen du
bist offen du bist frei und jedes tommy
wichtig und war eine lange reise und ich
hab jetzt bekommen ich habe alles
ausgefüllt
[Musik]
ich habe einfach schnurrbart hier
hast du das wir ja wohl haben groß
geworden sind und
uns ist an nichts gefehlt hat im
gegenteil sogar großer überfluss an alle
und der sich dann nach deutschland kamen
dass wir hierher geflohen sind zwar mit
dann im asylheim und da nochmal komplett
andere welt
das dass das war sehr schwierig ich habe
früh gereift viel
traurig
sein aber jetzt bin ich glücklich ich
sage ich bin geschafft
[Musik]
das war schon mitte mai wieder
es war mir wichtig mich in deutschland
wohl zu fühlen und irgendwann mal diese
hingabe haben zu sagen okay es ist jetzt
vieles anders es schwer integration ist
nicht einfach es erfordert sehr viel
hingabe es erfordert dass die gegenwart
akzeptiert und irgendwann mal als ich
dann im iran baum gesehen habe wie
depressiv teilweise menschen sind was
sie gerade durchmachen mit der politik
habe ich für mich die entscheidung
getroffen es reicht ich werde mich jetzt
zu 100 prozent integrieren ich werde
jetzt so viel gas gehen wie möglich und
das so gehört es nun mal auch deutsch zu
sein und auch tolerant gegenüber alle
andere nation zu sein durch zu sein
heißt für mich tolerant gegenüber alle
nationalitäten zu sein und das bin ich
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
sie haben ein technisch sehr entspannt
erst mal kaffee muss auf jeden fall sein
und dann schick ich von meinem profil
guckt was auf der welt los ist
[Musik]
ich bekomme noch mal wieder im netz
nachrichten von landminen oder auch
landsmänner die dann ließen deutsch
sprechen zum beispiel sprechen fließend
deutsch oder englisch und schreibe mir
dann auf deutsch bessere grammatik als
ich und mein hey ich lerne deutsch weil
ich habe die hoffnung immer nach
deutschland bekommen
und dann denke ich mir so waren wir das
ja schon privileg dass ich in freiheit
leben weil wer weiß ob die überhaupt
kommen können ist es ja sehr schwer vom
iran nach deutschland auszuwandern
ich bin nach deutschland um mit meinen
eltern als ich elf jahre alt war sie kam
nach deutschland weil seine mutter
einfach wollte dass wir frei aufwachsen
also waren auch politische flüchtlinge
weil mein papa auch gewisse probleme
auch mit dem start hatte und einer der
wichtigen gründe warum wir geflohen sind
das meine mutter einfach nicht wollte
dass ich gegen meinen willen
einkaufswagen
[Musik]
ja mein heimatland iran ist voll mit
menschen die einfach absolut
intelligente tolle menschen die einfach
für die welt was beitragen wollen ist
aber die werden halt von einem regime
einfach quasi unterdrückt
da gibt es sehr viele frauen vor allem
die da
immer noch die hoffnung haben so ein
funken hoffnung nach deutschland zu
kommen dann nach europa auszuwandern
das ist für viele einfach unmöglich ne
deswegen finde ich schon dass menschen
die in freiheit leben egal ob es in
deutschland ist amerika england dass man
schon dankbar sein sollte und die
möglichkeiten hier nutzen sollte den
personen mögen es ja schon uns auf so
stylen und mögen es ja einfach sehr
femininen sehr weiblich zu sein und im
iran machen das hat natürlich offene
frauen aber immer so mit dem
hintergedanken dass das irgendwie
verboten ist oder dass die polizisten
kommen können und
bin halt sehr sehr froh dass ich hier
einfach entspannt so wie ich will
rumlaufen kann dass ich auch mal was im
bauch frei tragen kann und wo dir wissen
wir auch raus ja lieb hat mein leben
extrem so nach meinen vorstellungen ein
bisschen zu sehr auf mein leben
fokussiert auf mich selbst und viele
männer sich jetzt nicht unbedingt eine
feste beziehung mit mir vorstellen
können
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja ich merke als comedian hat man schon
eine gewisse verantwortungsvoll also die
leute schauen sich die sachen an und wir
menschen lassen uns natürlich auch bei
meinungen sehr schnell beeinflussen ich
merke dass es immer mehr dass ich mich
damit mehr beschäftigen sollte was man
immer ich bin halt auch mancher song für
peter menschen sagt man sachen die ich
gar nicht zu 100 prozent so meine und
ich glaube in der heutigen zeit ist es
schon sehr wichtig sich auch mal
gedanken darüber zu machen was man jetzt
in die öffentlichkeit bringt
vorbereitung hier kannst du tiefen und
ich habe im leben so viel erlebt aber
das ist bei mir drin das ist nur eines
raus ich muss keine probleme kriegen
ihren ich habe schon welche herzlich
willkommen schön das
kurspotenzial wer hätte es kann ich mit
bekommen anfangen das war ironie also
ich verdiene trotzdem paul walter und
egal wie genau ich bin mega genau aber
ständig hab ich schon so ein bisschen
männliche stimme dabei viele männer
sagen du hast eine angenehme stimme das
hört sich gar nicht so feminin an kannst
du gar rote hilfe leicht jetzt spontan
parodien den canucks phoenix kann ich
gut moderieren das ist richtig weil
in meinem freundeskreis dann wird man
gesagt meine große gefährt heißt es
warten
es ist ja auch so oder so auch unter
last recht
kann man durch eure stimme
ich nutze die bühne nicht um mich
politisch zu äußern ich will mich da
nicht zu weit aus dem fenster lehnen
aber ich finde es schon ein statement
genug ich komme aus einem land wie iran
ich stehe auf der bühne
ich habe meine freie meinung ich mache
die witze die ich will über männer
frauen irgendwann später häufig auch
ganz viele frauen dass mein marx zu
helfen
die welt ist kleiner als man denkt man
halt durch corona gesehen wie verbunden
wir alle miteinander sind und wie sehr
wir uns brauchen und oder wünsche ich
mir was die politik auch eben das
einfach offene fragen schneller
beantwortet werden dass wir aus dieser
welt einfach besser gemeinsam leben
können
willst dann schau doch einfach in der
mediathek vorbei
[Musik]